bitte klarer ist eine vielschichtige
figur
man könnte sagen eine schwierige
persönlichkeit
[Musik]
man hat die ganze zeit so ein bisschen
noch beim zuschauen schwierigkeiten sie
zu mögen
[Musik]
wir möchten gerne wissen dass es näher
mit dieser frau auf sich hat und das
gibt sich eben dann im lauf der
geschichte allmählich preis wie so dass
man vor spiel auch so machen einfach
aufhören denn bis kein ehrgeiz den
eltern der viel daran beginnt damit dass
an einem morgen eine frau namens lager
aufladen
wir lernen sie kennen eine frau am ende
ihres arbeitslebens eine frau die an
diesem tag etwas ganz besonderes erleben
wird nämlich am abend wieder ein konzert
stattfinden eine komposition wird
uraufgeführt werden
der komponist bestückt ist das von sarah
und ganz dass lara aufgrund der
schauspielerin und aufgrund auch des
ganzen anderen auch so aber sind
empfehlen aber vor allem aufgrund dieser
interessant austarierten unbestimmtheit
eigentlich die ganze zeit sehr spannend
war
ich glaube ich erinnere mich erst sie
waren extrem ehrgeizig wahnsinnig weil
sich ja es ist eben eine spannung die
ganz von ihnen kommt die die
schauspieler entwickeln müssen die
ganzen den charakteren liegen es ist
kein kammerspiel jetzt im strengen sinn
denn unterwegs auf den straßen zwischen
den orten wie sehen sie denn noch ich
hätte nach 22 karten allerdings in den
hinteren sein nicht aber es ist im
geiste ein kammerspiel
ich würde sagen ja nolle gerster wir
damit sein publikum finden das ist die
mutter des künstlers das wirklich ohne
chance
wir müssen neben ihm sitzen das wäre
sicher eher ein bürgerliches publikum
sein publikum das an filme mit nassen
gewöhnt ist und was vielleicht auch aus
dem theater den corinna harfouch kommt
ja auch vom theater jene aufmerksamkeit
mitbringt die dieser film wohl verlangt
für die aber eben dann auch eine menge
lohnender dinge präsentiert er ist alles
was ich dir jemals gesagt
heute geht es nun dich
[Musik]
ich wusste dass ich es nicht als bis
nach oben schaffen würde
[Musik]
weil dann sind gehört lacht nein